so you know I have to ask you right your
your favorite on-screen kiss oh oh I
didn't realize that question was coming
my way
okay everyone it is time for the Drew's
News podcast where we're serving up all
the news you need a Sprinkle of Pop
Culture a splash of inspiration and
always with a side of good feels today
we're covering everything from Kate
Hudson's worst on-screen kiss to a new
study that finds social media has been
linked to brain changes in teens and we
have
Mako pilot here today it is Rusty Russ
Matthew that's right I'm on the podcast
everybody hello and I you know this
ain't our first time I have been here
before and when I'm not here I listen
every week really I love Drew and so
it's nice to just come back in here and
visit hi everybody and how you well I
don't know what the news is without you
frankly so here we go all right I'm
ready hit it all right should we head
some headlines no yes first of all
really quickly I want to just take a
quick pause will you please tell us
about this amazing Ross X Ross collab
that you're doing because the clothes
are so cute and the story behind it is
so Charming and it's actionable people
can actually buy this stuff yeah so you
know I'm a judge on RuPaul's Drag Race
hello season 15 airing now and you know
we know I think something show in the
world I love it so much and I'll tell
you when you want to go on that show and
sit next to Rupaul what do you wear I
had no idea and so what I decided to do
is just make it and I met this designer
when I was performing in Toronto someone
was sitting in the front row wearing a
jacket way shinier than mine and I said
take that off you can't upstage with my
own show and then I actually took it and
put it on and the audio started clapping
I was like how dare you it was better
than what I was wearing his name was
Ross Mayer and I decided let's partner
together so we have designed this entire
collection every week what I'm wearing
on a RuPaul's Drag Race uh it's
shoppable is shoppable because as soon
as the episode airs you can buy it uh
and it's affordable it's for all genders
it's for all sizes it's beautiful it's
called Ross by Ross is the the line
because his name is Ross Mayer I'm Ross
Matthews and I'm so proud of it I love
this I also love that you can have a
piece of it you know I love the
shoppability and accessibility of it
yeah it's accessible fabulosity is how I
think about it I feel like that's kind
of you in a nutshell accessible
fabulosity thank you drew I love you I'm
big on accessibility I love you more all
right here we go let's hit the headlines
first up Kate Hudson recently took
vanity Fair's lie detector test and was
forced to decide which one of her former
co-stars was the best on-screen kiss she
ever had when shown a picture of Dane
Cook her co-star from My Best Friend's
Girl Kate laughed and said oh no no no
no cancel cancel she was like no maybe
there's bad blood there I don't know I
don't know other a-listers have recently
revealed their best and worst on-screen
kisses including Zac Efron who called
his kiss was Zendaya in the greatest
showman his favorite Kiss ever which
makes me feel bad for any girl who's
ever dated Zac Efron that you are not
his favorite Kiss ever just so you know
there was the question was to all those
girls out there who were his girlfriends
or dated him they asked who was his best
on-screen kids oh so it's different I
think it's different okay so you know I
have to ask you right your your favorite
on-screen kiss oh oh I didn't realize
that question was coming my way
huh I will say as you think I have asked
you before if you on on our show on the
Drew Barrymore show if you've ever had
to kiss somebody in a movie that you
weren't feeling without naming names you
said of course of course and that's
really tough a hundred percent oh God I
can't even imagine oh it's it's so hard
anybody have a bad breath
um no luckily that's my worst fear
that's yeah no it's like the breath
isn't as bad as the person sometimes
understood and you're just like ugh I
have to be intimate with you and I think
you're such a dope
um okay who is the best like if you
could go back see a scene and still get
the butterflies
God why is this plaguing me have you
ever seen any of your movies they're
really good you should watch them I know
I'm like I'm so lucky I got to because
Matthew McConaughey Edward Norton Adam
Sandler Hugh Grant Ben Stiller oh my God
you're living my diary is what you're
living dear diary I Luke Wilson Oh God
who else I've gotten so lucky at all the
boys I've gotten to kiss for work you
know the funny thing is is that I I
don't know if anyone else is talking
about this but it's so mechanical and
the second you even if you can get into
it they like y'all cut or they're like
it's not in the right position or like
you see someone in the background like
you know distracted and not caring and
it kind of breaks the moment like it
it's it's a weird thing to kiss someone
in like this more professional setting
so you're never really not as sexy as
you would think it was see I'm I love
I'm a big fan of movies right and so I I
like to think about that maybe you guys
just got lost in it you know what I mean
you forgot the set and the crew was
there and like all that you just looked
up five minutes later like oh whoa I
forgot we were filming and I definitely
I dated Luke Wilson and Justin long and
I did movies with them and that was kind
of nice because you're like we're
boyfriend and girlfriends so it's not
like taboo and weird it's hard for me
when like the man is married because I'm
so hosed before bro sure so so that's
always awkward I I'm like I always get
uncomfortable what about when you're
dating somebody did you ever date
anybody like dating somebody while you
had to go to work and like make out with
somebody at work and then come home was
that ever weak 100 yes and it was weird
yes and jealousy yes you know who's fun
um I I did a film with Patty considine
yeah and
um I loved working with him he was such
a good guy great actor too
um brilliant and we played husband and
wife and we're trying to have a baby
it's this film miss you already with
Tony Collette and um it it just he was
he was such a safe person and I had just
given birth to my daughter Frankie and
so my hormones were just like coming up
in buckets everything was like throwing
me over the edge and he was like a safe
space for me and now when I watch House
of dragon I'm just like
I I played your like wife and now I
can't see you any other way with the
hole in your face yeah it's just rotting
with a rottenham
it's so funny I'm like oh I did a movie
with you and you were like handsome and
vivacious and here you are rocking this
iconic brilliant like just a character
that's kind of like he went to places
like I haven't seen other actors go hair
and makeup Wise It's like that character
is like a death's doorstep for a good
six episodes and I know that that
probably gets you hot for him you know
what I mean look at him like look at him
go that sure he's rotting and his face
is off but what that's hot shockingly
enough for us it did the opposite I was
like God Patty was so like alive and
handsome when I was playing his wife and
now he really it's because he is still
alive and handsome just for the record
right character like messes you up it's
like I I'm excited to see how Patty like
convinces everyone else on the planet
that he's not that like hole in the face
Crone that he plays in House of dragons
see I love it when people throw vanity
completely
he did more than any other actor I've
ever seen on the planet and it is a
brilliant performance you have to hand
it to him if he still had that hand
there he just brought it off now you
can't I mean I feel like a mouse was
about to crawl through as I thought it
was so gross watching that at one point
yeah
um on the topic of relationships a woman
recently went viral for writing about
how she recovered after her high school
sweetheart of over 10 years suddenly
broke up with her Julia writes that
after their 10-year relationship where
they moved to two different cities
together and they talked about marriage
often it took her nearly two years to
grieve the breakup but in that time she
has learned how to practice
self-compassion ask for help find
gratitude after the grief and even
forgive her ex for ending their
relationship I mean okay yeah I think
you should I'm glad you forgave your ex
but like can we also thank our EX
because somebody had to end this I'm
sorry like it's true we all in those
younger years get in these relationships
that are sort of they Define us I think
you know when you're in these are high
school sweethearts and you're 20. you
kind of think well this is who I am
forever but really you are still like
half baked at that age you know you
still need some time in the oven to cook
and I love when you see people who are
85 and they've been together since they
were you know 15 or something great I'm
so glad it worked for you let's go back
to real life now I think you know for
the majority of the majority of us like
I was in a 10-year relationship and I
was not great at it and I was terrible
but I learned so much in in that time
and that's what sort of primed me and
got me ready for when it was right I
think what has happened to her this
10-year relationship and now a couple
years to find who she is prediction
she's gonna be like married in two to
three years that's what I think because
that's the kind of stuff you go through
that teaches you what you can't learn
unless you actually do it
I also just like the positivity of it
the not sort of you know
um being angry at or feeling sorry for
yourself or staying stuck or even giving
the sentiment of you know I was robbed
of these 10 years you know or I have
nothing to show for it now I know those
are typical pitfalls that we can all
fall into yeah when we've dedicated a
portion of our life to being with
someone else but there are just no real
way to learn the lessons without the
experience so and I know it sounds
cheesy but you do think in those moments
you know I bet if you've been in
relationships that ended you think God
did I just waste five years of my life
with this person but no you're not
wasting anything because if if you're
paying attention you are learning
something you're going to take into your
next relationship which sounds I know
like people who are in the middle of it
right now they're like Ugh it's so
cheesy but it's totally true also I'm
gonna you know address the female
elephant in the room which is some women
who have a ticking biological clock and
can only have children and have a family
by a certain age they do tend to worry
oh my god did I waste five or six years
investing with this person because all
of the sudden now I think what's
interesting is we are starting to adapt
in society such a more open
lifestyle let alone dialogue of people
can have children on their own they can
you know do via surrogate they can
engage with a friend they can adopt it's
a different world we're not saying like
a family is a man and a woman and a
picket fence and 2.5 kids and we're not
in the 50s anymore
um but it is difficult when you're a
woman having been with someone for years
because you gotta think then you have to
meet someone then you want to get to
know them for a while you you know a lot
of people don't want to be pressured
right away or they don't want to jump
into a fan family Dynamic right away nor
should they they should be certain if
they can of something
and there's no real right or wrong way
to go about it in my humble opinion and
my lack of judgment to people but I know
it's tough for women sometimes who
literally go like now I can't
and there have probably been I know
there's been relationships out there
where if someone leaves you and you've
been with them during those pivotal
years of 30 to 40
it's really tough and and it is a
different conversation
um and not exactly the one we started
having with this high school sweetheart
she's I think got a whole window in
front of her and it's just you know I'm
I'm glad that she has that time and I
know it's hard for women who like think
oh my God that when window is closed and
that's what can lead to I think a real
Devastation of investing time and
thinking I don't have what I hoped to
show for it in the end but if you are
outside of that ticking clock window
then you should be excited for the
experience and never regret anything
because it's so informative and
necessary what else is living a life all
about yeah right the experience and the
connection and the try again but you
know I love having these combos with you
because that's something that's just not
on my radar when you talk about women in
that zone if they're in 40 if they want
to have children you know that is a time
to sort of think oh God so when you're
okay hold on this is like an uh I'm
having an epiphany a moment all my
friends yeah who I've been all my
girlfriends who have been like just go
have fun until you meet the right no
wonder they're feeling such pressure to
like meet somebody of course there's a
clock on that and I never thought about
that before yeah whoa that's a whole
different thing I know I'm so glad I'm
not a girl I gotta tell you I would be
so stressed out it's so easy being me it
really is my I'm like what what day you
want to do happy hour that's my biggest
concern
wow and yet as a woman I'm telling you
if any girl is you know or a man for
that matter is lucky enough to have you
in their life everything's gonna be okay
oh I love you that's true I love you I'm
seriously sorry to every girl I
pressured to go and just just calm down
and just it'll happen when it happens I
get it now I take it back and some
people do need to calm down and stop
stressing okay good because I don't
really take it back I mean a lot of you
do just need to chill out
all right we're gonna go to a quick
commercial break and we'll be right back
with exciting interesting news about Wes
Bentley from Yellowstone
and we're back okay Yellowstone star Wes
Bentley who was so amazing in American
Beauty and kind of came onto the scene
and just was revelatory I'll never
forget that watching that movie and
being like who is he right exactly you
and everyone in the industry and I feel
like the American public absolutely well
he recently opened up about drug
addiction and how it deeply impacted his
career leading up to his role on the hit
show Yellowstone because as a young
adult in the entertainment industry and
after his success in American Beauty Wes
said it was all vampires and
underdeveloped young people he said the
regrets are always going to be there but
he has been sober since 2009 and is
happily married and has a whole life now
that he really feels good about
um thoughts well it's interesting that
when he says the regrets are always
going to be there I'm curious what you
think about regret do you think they're
healthy to have or do you think it's
just um a weight and a waste of time to
focus on things you can't change the
only things I truly regret in life is
anything that I've done to sabotage my
health
oh that's interesting that I regret and
I can't take it back and I just I I'm
always concerned I you know I smoked
I've dranked I've beat up my body I
didn't eat healthy for a lot of years
and you know how and you know how's that
going to impact me in the long run and
where does that show up in certain ways
and places and for that I have a
Perpetual fear for sure interesting
um other than that I regret nothing and
I really encourage people not to have
regrets because you just can't change
the past you can change your future
though because of the hats going back to
the experience the life the things you
learn what you've been taught how you
grow that's all Gonna Save The Looking
forward and don't waste your time
looking in the review mirror so that's
like that's how I feel about regret I
feel pretty much the same way I always
used to say no regrets no regrets no
regrets but I I do think it's okay to
look at your past whether it's with your
health or your behavior or something and
sort of say and hold on to it in terms
of not to get lost and I wish I would I
wish I could I wish I did this but to
think I will never do that again I will
do this again I learned from that and
it's sort of like a line through some of
these stories we're talking about yeah
there is a reoccurring theme here right
that like life experience is valuable in
if if you use it to go forward you know
what I mean that's the best part about
living is that you're sort of armed with
what you didn't know before and you know
you can stop making those same mistakes
also you know I think it was in season
too I mean I always was so honest about
you know everything in my life pretty
much but for some reason season two
became like a real mission for me you
know with you and sort of doing stuff on
digital for the show which was like I
want this to be an Invitational Place
why should we pretend that we are
veneers with no past so when a Wes
Bentley you know who probably didn't
have to disclose these things is like
yes everything looks great now but it
there have been times in my life where I
really struggled and I think when
certain people hear that it's just
extremely comforting and non-alienating
the hardest thing is when you feel so
alone so isolated so lost you know so
disconnected from other people and so
it's like when you hear somebody go oh
man I had demons I got LED down the
wrong path I fought my way back I'm
thriving now that's the kind kind of
invitation and realities and stories I
want to hear from people and then you
get to the humor and the awesomeness and
it's like listen it's just not all
perfect and Rosy you fall off you get
back on that is life so I applaud him
for bringing people into his life
experience when he probably didn't have
to absolutely and it's another through
line in this conversation Ali that we're
having this accessibility I think these
honest conversations are so accessible
to audiences well I think it's why you
resonate I think our show resonates is
because no matter where anybody watching
is on that journey of falling in the
horse and getting back on they see that
reflected in you no matter where they
are I can never see that in myself
because I just don't have that ability
like I don't want to know what other
people think and feel about me but I
like him more now for sure yeah so if
that's what you're talking about that's
what I'm talking about cool okay I see
it with West Ben yes accessible and
fabulosity but accessible human vanity I
mean if people are going to talk about
their problems and then just stay stuck
in them and sit in them and like let the
room stink up I don't want anything to
do with that no interest thank you next
I want to hear about the scars and the
triumphs yeah and like
um the drive the drive to to to be the
best version of ourselves even in the
messiest version of ourselves oh I love
a good mask thank you I love a hot mess
all right moving on to the topic of
social media there is a new study from
the University of North Carolina that
has identified a possible link between
frequency checking social media and
brain changes that are associated with
having less control of impulse Behavior
among young adolescents oh God I just
got a pit in my stomach as a parent yeah
what does this mean exactly I'm trying
to wrap my head around this well I mean
I I just went to myself the second I get
a device in my hand I keep checking
things I don't need to like the weather
or Instagram or text and then it's like
the moon you know I don't know where the
Moon is and then I'm like wait did I
check the text oh wait no I've already
done that oh wait some news stories and
it's like I am a rat on a feeder no it
is like an addiction it feels like for
me I grab one if wake up in the morning
it's the first thing I do and then
there's just like this like routine
Instagram Facebook Twitter and there's
nothing new when I go on but I do the
rotation and it's like almost what was
the like they call it an Impulse here
that's what it feels like I'm like why
am I refreshing what am I looking for
and by the way you just did it 10
seconds ago there's still nothing I know
and yet it's that like rat on a feeder
that I really relate to and I'm like oh
that's impulse control and if young kids
are having that depleted that's a bad
time to be losing sight of how to
control impulses sure and I also think
about the great thinkers and the great
artists of you know human human the span
of humanity what what happened if like
Leonardo da Vinci had Twitter it was
just refreshing rather than creating the
next Masterpiece you know what I mean
like what kind of Masterpiece could we
be creating if we weren't checking
Facebook Drew you know it was Leonardo
da Vinci's version of Twitter though the
Town Square literally I yeah I guess it
was the literal Town Square
like carrier pigeon
you know they had Hot Gas back in the
day I know that's been happening like
you know like back in like really like
beginning of man times totally someone
and woman time someone was like Sally is
just really pissing me off right now
carrying her weight in the cave like I
cannot handle this we write ye old
gossip column just with a feather pen
a quill quill yeah my feather pen a
quill yeah oh I'd be like Dear Abby lady
whistle blower
totally I know but I mean think about
that like so these great thinkers who
are now being born are now in their you
know 20s or something are they
distracted by technology and not doing
what they're meant to be doing I mean
time will tell time will tell I know
because we it's still like it it's
here's a phrase I hadn't heard until the
other day someone said uh I Jen as in
like the oh God that's good isn't it so
good where is that phrase been I Jen
because I'm like gen z a millennial I'm
a little confused which is which that's
the next one that should be it hi Jen
the other day I was at a restaurant and
they they these adults were all talking
and then the kid was watching an iPad
and I was thinking like oh wow are they
going to learn how to engage or how to
sit and be quiet or not be there and I'm
not parent judging I'm not I'm thinking
about
what that life experience is going to be
like for that child and that is maybe
igen I think it's like the zero to ten
yeah you know as well as the 10 to 20.
like you know call it zero to Fifteen I
don't know but like all of a sudden it
was like I my skin and chills and like
hair stood up igen yeah and and again I
don't know if it's a good thing or a bad
thing so if parents who are listening
now have done that with the kids I'm not
judging you but I it's going to be
interesting to see with this eye gen
turns out to be because these kids are
also the kids who for three years went
to school on Zoom you know I thought the
other day
um and I'm I don't want this to be
controversial
um but I thought about how being
um through Wars and plagues and civil
liberties and everything has been
um cyclical in our world we take a step
forward we take a step backwards we have
content ended with issues time and time
again
but the internet is a new thing that we
can't hearken back to history and say
we're repeating ourselves we're going
backwards this is an untested uh format
that we don't know the effects of we've
never been here before it's unchartered
right and
um I wish we hadn't been to any of these
places you know before but this is
something we have no comparison to not
that we should have the comparison to
anything else
um I I mean I'm so ridiculously flowery
and that I wish you know we came onto
this planet and we took care of each
other and we learned to live amongst our
differences and we gave each other the
room and space for acceptance and that
was how the world worked but it isn't
the history we know and we're getting
into a present
that just we have nothing to compare it
to
you know with every like great
technological advance in and there have
been a few of them that have really sort
of changed the game with how we interact
with each other as humans right you
think about the telephone think about
how that changed everything there's
always good and with the good and the
advances and stuff there's always sort
of a dark part of it you know like you
look at the dark web we don't know how
that's going to affect us even with
telephones telemarketers came hello
they're annoying and they're never going
to go away either but in all seriousness
who knows how this is going to do like
the internet and all of that the
negative parts of it the way the proof
the isolating Parts can survive it
well we have been surviving it but it's
a brand new existence the human
existence is different now than it was
before it you know and I don't know what
that's going to mean for igen I don't
know yeah I'm raising kids in it and
it's it's I think it's why I think about
it so much because it's it's going to
affect them and they're going to be the
example of what that is and we cut to 30
50 100 years from now if we take care of
our planet and we're able to be here we
really won't know until then yeah and by
then it'll be just a standard passe Norm
but we're really in the Wild Frontier of
the unknown right now yeah but it's
exciting it is exciting yeah I do I do
think there's always a polarity to a
positive and a negative you know so I I
get heavy about it when I talk about it
because I think it just weighs on me so
much as a parent you know if it was just
me it would be like come what may but
now that I have these kids I just I I
everything I I you know weighs on me in
such a different way wow so interesting
that's why I love talking to you about
this because it's like you are driving
your own car but then you have these
other really important cars that you're
taking care of before your own you know
and I just think I can I don't know how
you function in the world I mean it's
I'm exhausted just worrying about myself
dear I'm I'm a lot by the way if I make
it through this like without heartbreak
and like just you know some type of
physical failure because I've never
cared this much and I don't even know if
it's sustainable like you know like if I
make it through as a parent I will be so
happy I just sometimes I think it's just
gonna take me down because I've never
worried or cared about anything this
much and can I physically sustain this
level of concern well I'll tell you just
like you don't you can't see yourself
and what you're doing on the show you're
talking about that conversation about
how you're relatable and it's helping
people in their Journeys you can't see
yourself as a parent so I just want you
to hear me me that I'm watching you and
you're doing a great job you can sustain
it I love you you're doing over hugging
we're hugging I love you
no sometimes you need someone to to show
you to tell you what you can't see I
need that because I'm a light happy
person you know but every person has a
dark side in the middle of the night
when your eyes blink up you're like it's
the world the world well let's go to our
last story oh and it's a light one I
love this story by the way you gotta
lighten it up if you go to the dark side
or the heavy you better pull yourself
out or lean on a friend who will can uh
what is it when you're on the plane and
you like you do their character oh the
ejector button yeah but it's like isn't
there a word yeah it's ejector button
right okay yeah I'll need our ejector
buttons all right our last story
um and talk about a real catastrophe a
curious feeling I was feeling frisky and
adventurous on a recent United Airlines
flight and escape from its carrier the
cat roamed the Blaine's cabin until it
was eventually caught by a flight
attendant who brought it around to
passengers asking politely is anyone
missing a cat oh ultimately the cat was
reunited with its owner Roxy
I I mean come on why couldn't I be on
this flight can I tell you something if
a little kitty walked up to me on a
flight I'd be the happiest human you
know I know that there are safety
protocols we need to follow but if
animals could just roam around a plane
think about like the joy the comedy the
surprise and Delight you know other than
like the poop and pee part I just have
to say I wish more animals were on more
flights roaming free and coming up and
surprising you like give me that Dr
Doolittle Airline and I will be a loyal
customer or do you know what they call
this Airline it's a feline Airline and
you know okay do you think do you want
to hear the really worst joke that I
have do you think this cat was in coach
or first Clause
I'm done I'm done that's it
just give me air Kitty any day
oh my God that's what I consider the
friendly Skies animal riddled flight
thank you oh well you know what that's
what we need in life you know right when
we sort of get you know a little heavy
in our heart it's just like where are
the humorous stories or the fun little
anecdotes or the little pop cultures or
the funny little you know facts and and
human moments uh or animal moments that
occur that just kind of like bring you
out of your own weird little slump and
that's what I always wanted to do here
with this news is like just when I need
it most I hear about a cat roaming
around a United Airlines flight and I'm
right I'm on that flight right now
watching that flight attendant like
holding the cat like excuse me are you
missing a cat like and I just feel
better I feel better too because if
there's turbulence you just go no that
cat's got nine lives we're fine and
we're fine we're good
well everybody out there uh Ross you're
on drag Grace oh yeah Dragway season 15
airing right now every Friday night on
MTV the highest rating Sam TV in like
six years it's just great the show is
phenomenal I'm so proud to be on it it
has so many spin-offs at such a powerful
thing it wins Emmy after Emmy I mean are
you so proud and Beyond Beyond and you
know it we've been doing the show
forever and it just is the same show
we've always done like me Roo Michelle
Visage Carson kressley which always just
trying to put something good out in the
world and make each other laugh and it
just feels like the rest of the world
caught up to us at a certain point you
know and then now it's just become a
juggernaut I love the combination of a
powerful business and something that
makes the world a better place totally
and that's what intersects with you guys
in your show all right well follow the
Drew's News podcast wherever you get
your podcasts and if you like you know I
don't know I want to like tell that cat
on that United Airlines flight like hey
you should listen to the Drew's News
podcast or you know
um I don't know like who else else would
you tell Rossi you did the pilot tell
the pilot listen to Drew's news and by
the way there's a cat back in e e f g or
whatever the seed is what airline is
that yes
no but tell your friend tell your sister
tell your your grandma and them that uh
Drew's news is every week uh with Drew
Barrymore I love that you do this
podcast it's an extension of what we do
on the show it's the kind of news you
want to hear about I love that it's all
the feels as you can use yeah I love
that you let us go there thank you drew
no I love you so much this is so much
fun all right everybody as we always say
we make this show for you so take it
with you
foreign